Testament text in the world
is in Manchester.
It is a passage of the Gospel of John,
and it was, they dated to about 120 80.
So let's say John died in nine 80,
some people think he died in a hundred.
So 20 years later, we have the text of what John wrote.
And so you're going to hear people say,
will the bundles change?
And people have changed it. Just say, go to Manchester.
People make sense? Okay.
I don't know what I told you all that.
Um, okay, so what are some reasons
we can trust the canon page?
What is that? Page five?
What are some reasons we can trust the canon?
Well, the Bible says we can trust the king.
Anything wrong with that?
What? Self. Self-referential. Self-referential.
It might be called circular object.
So I can say to you, uh, give me a thousand dollars
and I'll give it back to you tomorrow.
I myself said, so
Almost A thousand dollars.
Okay, so what's wrong with that? Or what's right with it?
If enough People say it,
The preponderance of the evidence
of saying the same thing.
Okay. So one thing we can do is look at the historicity
of people over the last, you know, what is it?
How many thousands of years?
Uh, going back at least four, uh, 2,500 years,
and how that's worked out for them, right?
Uh, and that is one thing the Bible says is pass it down
to your children and your children's children.
Uh, because, uh, it is true. It is, it, it works.